Marjan:
We’re going into the belly of
the beast.
Can you handle it?
♪♪
I'll see it through.
Tamar:
The Mossad sent me to Tehran on
a mission.
(Sirens and tires squealing)
Tamar:
But then everything went
wrong.
(Detonator clicking and car
exploding)
♪♪
Tamar:
We have to go. Now.
♪♪
Tamar:
Half the guard is looking
for us.
♪♪
We can't get out.
(Guns firing)
♪♪
Marjan:
You're a good agent, Tamar.
We failed this operation, but it
wasn't for nothing.
♪♪
Marjan:
We're playing a long game here.
Tamar:
Who sent you?
♪♪
Trust me.
This operation is highly
classified.
Yulia:
We need to stop him cold.
♪♪
You went back to work for them?
Tamar:
I had no choice.
Marjan:
If you pull this off,
we'll help you escape.
Marjan:
Can you handle it?
♪♪
I'll see it through.
I know you will.
♪♪
Yulia:
It will be maximum security,
dozens of Sepah agents.
♪♪
Be careful.
Yulia:
Faraz knows Tamar better than
anyone in Iran.
Yulia:
I trust you to take care of
them.
♪♪
Marjan:
We're are going into the belly
of the beast.
♪♪
Milad's not train for this.
He can do it.
Amir:
We have trouble.
♪♪
There's been a change of plans!
Milad:
I'm getting us out!
Tamar:
There's no getting out!
♪♪
If we screw this up, I might not
be able to protect you.
♪♪
This plan could fail, and expose
our entire network.
♪♪
Marjan:
Everything depends on it.
♪♪
Tamar:
Do you realize what you've done?
I'm saving us!
♪♪
Yulia:
It's putting us all at risk.
This operation is not to be
compromised.
♪♪
You might not get out of there
alive.
♪♪
Tamar:
I have to make it right.
♪♪